there's something
important about that year 1968 that
you're talking about because that is
also the year
that america was just basically burning
down that was the same year that mlk was
shot
that bobby kennedy right so i remember
you told the story this is the
documentary i think accidental courtesy
is the name
right yeah which i've watched several
times you told the story that you were
watching
i believe i dream of jeannie now
absolutely the other one bewitched
bewitched how can i get those two wrong
they're two basically uh
you're watching bewitched they they both
are beautiful women yes elizabeth
montgomery and barbara eden
facts so you were watching uh bewitched
um and breaking news came on walter
cronkite came on
and basically announced that martin
luther king was assassinated
and you're the one that told your father
the news
correct me if i'm wrong and he broke
down
crying and this was actually the first
time that you saw your father
crying tell me about that moment
i didn't understand it uh first of all i
didn't really know who martin
king was at the time really yeah i you
know i spent
you know a lot of my formative years
overseas and so you know we weren't
having
you know civil rights marches and all
that kind of thing over there
uh so but when um i you know it happened
in the middle of my program and usually
um it was something significant you know
that everybody could relate to
whenever a newscaster you know burst
into a middle of a program
and since i didn't know who mlk was
i didn't understand you know people you
know die
all the time i didn't understand the
significance of it
as to why this could not wait for the
six o'clock news why did you have to you
know burst into my program
why are you messing up my bewitched
favorite program precisely
so but i figured it had to be something
important and maybe i just didn't know
who it was so i wanted to kill my father
maybe even he would know and as soon as
i mentioned it
he was in his little office typing and
as soon as i mentioned that his hand
made his head fell into his hands and he
said oh no
no no no no no you know and he was like
i'm not going to know what's going on
here
and he began sobbing about it and i just
did not understand that
i've never you know i've seen my mom cry
i've never seen my dad cry
um but who is this person that you know
that's making
you know my father cry you know what it
is it's not a relative
you know and so he began explaining all
the things
that mlk had done uh he had also marched
with the mlk your father yes yes wow
and um you know i so it was something
going on in your head that you knew
something was way off your father's
crying breaking news
something is different going on even at
age 10 yeah you seem like you were very
innocent at that time that something's
changed within you at that point
uh no not not right then um
i just understood that you know this
this person
was was a very significant person but i
wasn't feeling it
because i did i still didn't know but uh
that evening things began burning
you know and a lot of violence and
rioting
and um it was just
crazy and and and everything changed and
then i began feeling it because
my world changed uh as i explained a few
minutes ago
uh all of my friends uh were white
okay and the next the next day
um april 5th because he was assassinated
on the fourth
uh we went to we lived in boston
initially
well when we first returned my father
was was working on on his um
on his uh master's degree at uh at bu
boston university
so we lived nearby and uh
we would you know we went down into
boston and picked up some of my friends
from the first school that i went to the
school was so bad
that we had to move to the suburbs it
was so behind
so we moved to the suburbs for betty
school that's why we were in belmont
after after you know almost weeks after
i started school
so we went and picked up some friends of
mine my little classmates from boston
and brought them out to belmont to stay
at our home because things were just too
dangerous
in boston buildings were burning down
everywhere people were fighting in the
streets
looting and all kinds of craziness and
so i saw that firsthand
and all in the name of this new word
that i had learned a couple months prior
called racism so uh you know
my world was beginning to change but the
real changes occurred
because you know as a 10 year old kid
you know you have lots of friends and
you play
and you get together after school after
your homework you go outside and play
with them all that has stuff
well guess what uh all of my friends
being white
in belmont uh some of them were no
longer
allowed to play with me not by my by my
parents
but by their parents and their parents
had always been very nice
to me uh i'd come over to their home
and if they were eating their parents
would invite me in and fix me whatever
their kid was eating
and i was at the table eat with them and
then we'd go outside and play same thing
that they were in my house my mom would
give them whatever i was having
you know there was no you know color
issue
and now all of a sudden i'm being told
when i knocked on the door
oh you know little johnny can't come out
you know he's staying
he's singing today you know for no
reason that was right after 1968 you're
saying like right now
it was the next day the next day wow
okay uh and then half an hour later i
see the guy down at the park
and i'd be like i thought you couldn't
come out uh no
um my mom doesn't want me playing with
somebody the kid straight up told you
that
yeah wow and uh and i i i say why
i don't know she just doesn't oh
the kid didn't even know wow right he
didn't know okay uh in retrospect
i understand it you know because we
lived in a duplex
uh the landlady lived on you know
downstairs and we lived upstairs
and there were two front doors right on
the front of the house birds and arms
are going straight upstairs we had all
that space there uh
now at the age of 10 you know i i
thought of her as an old lady
i don't know how old she was she may
have been 30.
[Laughter]
i just turned 40 darryl you're making me
feel horrible well yeah we
we gotta figure you know at age 10 you'd
be ancient right 40.
so uh you know but you know she was
probably
my parents age maybe a little bit older
uh you know
young by today's standards you know in
any regard but uh but at age 10 yeah
anybody over
over 15 was probably old um anyway
she owned the house and we had a big
porch
and sometimes my friends and i who play
on the porch set up little army soldiers
or whatever that we did
there was no line going down the center
of the porch
that designated my side and her side and
she was super nice
if she made cookie she always bring us
some give to me and my friends on the
porch or whatever
well guess what just the next day or the
day after whatever
you know following day uh we were
playing on the porch
and she came out she said daryl i'd
rather you play on your side of the
porch
and then she said um i'd rather you all
not play on the porch at all why don't
you go inside
this is a white lady this is the white
lady and and
and this was the person that i knew as a
nice white lady
i mean she was always nice to us and now
why is this uh
lady being so mean uh i didn't know
there was a side to the
porch she said i'd rather you play on
your point on your side
i didn't know there was a sigh i mean
the whole time i've been there i've been
playing all over the porch
and now of a sudden the porch has a side
where's this invisible line that i'm not
seeing
and then she's telling me uh not to play
on the porch
i i need to play inside uh you know
what's going on here
i didn't get it in retrospect of course
i get it now
because racial tension was so
high and you gotta understand that era
this is
in the middle of the civil rights
movement martin luther king's home was
getting bombed
you know by the clan uh all kinds of
things were happening
um ever has been assassinated on and on
and um here this lady is sending me
inside my house who used to be so nice
so in retrospect she was trying to
protect
me and my family as well as her and her
property
because you know we were like in an
all-white neighborhood and suppose you
know somebody driving by
realized oh this white lady is renting
to a black family uh
maybe we should come burn across in her
yard yeah if you remember
was the kkk prevalent in boston at that
time
absolutely so even in the northeast
this isn't just a southern thing you're
saying no no no it's not
it was not um and uh if you remember
viola louisa
uh viola louisa was a white lady who uh
you know participated in in our civil
rights back in the 60s and she was
driving a black civil rights activist
to go to a march and the clan happened
to see her on the highway
as they were driving there to protest
the march or whatever
and while she was driving they pulled up
alongside her car
and shot her in the face murdered her
right there on the highway
uh the you know the car ran you know she
was shot dead while he was driving
and of course the car veered off the
road and crashed
uh the black guy survived he was in the
passenger seat
but she did not and all because
she had a black man she was a white
woman uh
you know driving a black man around uh
now you know
in later years like just back let's say
1992
or three um when i was
uh interviewing this one clan leader um
shortly after i interviewed him he
uh went to prison for he and one of his
clansmen
he pulled up to a stoplight in his town
here in maryland
at the stoplight right in the main
intersection of town
uh there was a vehicle to the right had
a black driver and a white
and a white woman in the passenger seat
and he and the classman of the classroom
got out dragged him out of the truck
and beat him within inches of his life
they left him in the street for dead and
drove off
in front of 11 witnesses